Hold onto your heads and watch your step
around the giant pit of dead bodies,
because we have the scariest horror
film if you happen to have hay fever.
Netflix's "In the Tall Grass" is a mind-bending
horror film from Vincenzo Natali
based off the novella by
Stephen King and Joe Hill.
And in this video, we're going to be taking a deep dive into its ending and shed some light on the meaning of
the Black Rock, the church, the field,
the monsters, and the time loop itself.
So follow me into the
grass, because here we go.
The ending of "In the Tall Grass" is actually the beginning, but this time the time loop has been broken.
Whereas the beginning of the film
sees Becky and Cal head into the grass,
the end sees them move away from it.
And that's all because of Tobin, who
we'll find is the key to breaking the loop.
But to fully understand the ending,
we must first understand the beginning.
Since the film, like
the field, is its own loop.
We start outside the
church and we end there too.
This time, however, with the characters
having grown through their journey.
The first time Becky and
Cal head into the grass,
we're picking up clues as
to how the field operates.
Everything about it is distorted:
direction, sound, and even time itself.
When we later meet
Travis, Becky's ex-boyfriend,
he tells Becky and Cal that
they've been gone for two months,
but for them, it's only been about a day.
If one day in the field is two
months in the real world,
we can speculate this loop has repeated at least 60 times since Becky and Cal's initial venture into the grass.
This is how Travis is able to
see Becky's decomposed body.
He is seeing a previous loop version of
her that wasn't successful at getting out.
But before we get too into
the mysteries of the field,
it's important to know why Becky and Cal
are driving through Kansas in the first place.
Although you may think Becky's child is a subplot of
the film, it's actually what propels the story forward.
You see, Becky used to be with Travis and
then she got pregnant, which Travis didn't like.
He left her and she decided to give the
child up for adoption to a family in San Diego.
Hence, Becky and Cal
driving across the country.
It's only at the end that Becky decides
to keep the baby and drive back home.
The tall grass has given her redemption.
Travis arguably has an
even stronger character arc.
He put himself and his career
before Becky and the child,
even encouraging
Becky via the "A Word".
I can't say it or YouTube
will demonetize me.
Travis was a musician, just like Ross, but unlike
Ross didn't give up his career to focus on a family.
As Ross says,
But as Travis goes on his own
journey, he sees the error of his ways,
sacrificing himself so that the girl
he loves and his unborn child can live.
He went from wanting to - rhymes with "cohort" -
his own child to sacrificing himself to save it.
Talk about a pretty big arc.
But this whole ending would never
have taken place if it weren't for Tobin.
He is the only character that is successfully
able to break free from the tall grass
in order to stop the loop from continuing.
About halfway through the movie, we
see Tobin beckoned into the grass by Travis.
But Travis went into the grass
because he saw Becky's car,
and Becky was beckoned
into the grass by Tobin.
This is the loop. It's kind of like asking
what came first, the chicken or the egg.
There's no logical explanation
for who entered the field first.
It's stuck in this loop,
bound to forever repeat itself.
The film, however, does give us
some interesting clues in Easter eggs.
For example, the novel Becky drops before she
heads into the field, the same one Travis picks up,
is "Jane Eyre", the story of a
young woman coming into adulthood
who has a child with a man she
had a tumultuous relationship with.
Sound familiar?
But to understand Travis's sacrifice,
we must first take a look at the Humboldt family
and Ross's fascination with the Black Rock.
The Black Rock, according to
Ross, predates Native Americans.
It's the geographic center of North America and was carved even before the glaciers carried the hills away.
Ross even calls it the
center of the center.
On its surface are carved symbols,
like this one with outstretched
hands, which we'll see later,
and of the grass people
hoisting a pregnant woman.
The carvings therefore are
a prophecy of what's to come.
The Black Rock also happens to be the
name of the church outside the tall grass.
In fact, it's called the Black
Rock of the Redeemer,
because every character, with perhaps the
exception of Tobin, who does eventually get out,
has something to
redeem about themselves.
But this church isn't here to worship God.
It's here to worship the Black Rock.
There are no Christian symbols in it, no
pulpits, just a solitary locked door at the back.
The closest thing you do get to a Christian
symbol are these carvings of a stained-glass here,
but even the tint of it
is green, like the grass,
green also symbolizing sickness.
At the back is a solitary door, which
can only be opened from the inside.
Tobin is able to open it after
he's transported there by Travis.
After Travis touched the Black
Rock, he was given its powers,
powers which according to
the rock can help find a way out.
By touching the Black Rock, Travis was
able to see the different holes within the field.
We get a glimpse of such a hole when Freddy the
golden retriever moves through this hole here
and winds up across from the church.
It's these holes that Ross
also used to catch his victims.
He could always catch them because
he knew where to go while they didn't,
but the Black Rock
corrupts as it did to Ross,
slowly taking control of its victims.
Ross used to be a Christian man so
much so that he was in a gospel band,
but the Black Rock corrupted him, turning
his faith away from God and toward the Rock.
When Becky has her child next to the
Black Rock, the ground beneath it splits open,
revealing hundreds of souls
the Black Rock has corrupted.
Their hands reach upward,
almost as if pleading for help.
We know countless others
have been brought into the field
just by looking at the different eras of cars
that have collected dust in the church's parking lot,
cars from the 50s, 60s, present day, and all from different states, according to the license plates.
When Ross attacks Cal, we also see
more decomposed bodies laying in the field.
Who knows how many
litter its vast expanse?
Then there's also the
question of the green people.
That's what they're
called in the end credits.
They are the force behind the Black Rock
and the people depicted on the carvings.
They are different than the
people beneath the rock,
their faces are made of grass and
they themselves are corrupted.
When Ross's eyes turned green here,
it's an indicator that the green people are
acting through Ross via the Black Rock.
They can control the grass, bending it to
its will as well as move organic material,
but once something is no longer living,
they lose the ability to control it.
As Tobin says multiple
times throughout the film,
The green people want flesh to fuel the grass
and lure more living things into its grasp.
The decomposition of dead
bodies helps fertilize the land,
and if the green people are
to survive, they need to feed.
As Ross says later on in the film,
Touching the Black Rock gives the possessed person a window into the field's many holes and branching paths,
because it will help that
person track down more victims.
It will help them see.
Even when Ross loses all
of his eyesight, he says,
Director Vincenzo Natali focuses
a lot on eyes throughout the film.
Here's one of the opening shots of Becky,
another of a dead crow,
and check out this shot when
Travis touches the Black Rock.
It looks just like the veins
coming out of an eye.
Eyes being deceiving is also manifested in the
scene where Cal makes Becky eat her own child.
Notice how the edges
of the screen are blurred,
and how Cal magically turns into Ross.
It calls into question whether what Becky
is seeing happened the way we think it did,
or perhaps this did happen and what we're
seeing is just another unsuccessful loop.
As Tobin says,
In the final showdown, Ross tries to
make his son touch the Black Rock,
once again bringing up
the theme of redemption.
But didn't we already see
Tobin touch the Rock?
How is he already not corrupted?
We did, but this is a new loop, another
chance for our characters to redeem themselves.
In the nick of time, Becky saves Tobin by
stabbing Ross with a Benny's Crab Shack necklace.
We're never given too much
information as to the significance of this,
but it's first seen when Travis enters the grass
and takes it from Becky's decomposing corpse.
It seems that this item has
some sort of significance to him,
perhaps it was a memento of a time he and
Becky spent together living in New Hampshire.
I'm assuming that's where they're from
judging by Becky's New Hampshire plates,
although it's never mentioned in the film.
After Travis kills Ross and
touches the Black Rock,
he's infused with the power
of being able to see the exit,
and quickly takes off with Tobin
before the corruption can take over.
He gives him the necklace
as proof that he loves crabs,
I mean, he's telling the
truth about the grass.
Becky and Cal decide not to go in the
grass, but Becky goes one step further,
deciding to go the opposite way and drop
off Tobin at the police station in Topeka
as well as keeping her baby.
The events that unfolded in the grass
have somehow made her change her mind.
With Tobin, Becky, and Cal no longer
going into the field, the loop has been closed,
but this doesn't mean more
people can be swayed into its orbit.
We did see all those
cars outside the church,
so new loops will continually spring up,
bringing its victims in an endless
cycle on the path to redemption.
And a church, or at least a building that resembles
one, is such a fitting physical representation of this.
The Christian faith is all about
finding redemption through Christ,
absolving our sins
through the power of God.
The Black Rock takes on this role,
offering redemption in a different form.
One of the big flaws of this
film is Cal's redemptive arc.
I felt like he didn't have one,
which makes it doubly unsatisfying,
since his character
also gets out of the loop.
His character really hasn't changed.
The film sets up Cal's flaw as being
unable to let go of his sister,
especially when it comes to Travis.
This causes friction between the two,
eventually culminating in him
throwing Travis from the Bowl-a-Rama.
For Cal to have a satisfying arc,
we'd need to see him accept letting
his sister go, but we never saw that.
Instead, we see him pleading for her not
to go, which ends up getting him killed.
His flaw leads to his own death,
but he is still rewarded at the
end by getting out of the loop,
something I would have changed
in the second act for his character
in order to make the ending
more emotionally fulfilling.
Overall, I enjoyed "In the Tall Grass",
a lot more than some of the derivative horrors
that have been lately coming out in theaters.
It's a film that makes you think,
has some gorgeous cinematography,
and didn't feature any
children of the corn.
I hope you enjoyed this video.
Let me know what you thought of
the movie in the comments below,
and please give it a thumbs up and subscribe
with the bell on to get more Think Story videos.
You can also find me
on Twitter @ThinkStoryYT.
And until next time remember,
Daddy loves you very much.